hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Emily wants to play my
buddy Wayne told me about this game and
said that it was pretty good and I
should check it out the only thing is it
costs money on Steam so I'm gonna play
it that way you guys can see if it's
actually worth the money so let's go to
it I don't know what to expect
hello the pizza's here
oh oh oh wait who's that Emily with a
who Emily Wu's seems a little bizarre
but I actually played a game a while ago
called pizza deliveries in the new hope
hey let me get into the backstory of it
son of a [ __ ]
hello look with right mouse button to
interact huh there we go wide to move
shift to run interact with right zoom
with middle and flashlight with left if
you have one and I don't have one I do
see a whoa did I just now notice that it
was that always here hello let's take
this they don't care about me they never
loved me oh so sad is this where I feel
bad for Emily hello I just poke you in
the eyeballs oh this is not good [ __ ]
you
seems like someone's trying to sell me
something okay hello hi how's it going
anybody
no okay hey buddy how you doing friend
you having a good time cuz I certainly
am NOT I don't know why I would want to
do that ever
let's play oh no oh no oh no oh no get a
new door pick up Emily's meds
that Emily's family the loving family
there's a knife can I have the knife
thank you enough of that thank you very
much
is that Oh checkers pizza I got the
pizza meter that's where I am but I
remember this game a long time ago that
I played called peace of delivery or
something like that it was just oh hi it
was utterly ridiculous this doesn't seem
oh I'm brave I'm a brave boy I got my
big boy pants on roughly oddly enough
today I'm not wearing pants and that's
not a lie I recently admitted on Twitter
that I don't always not wear pants
tragedy I know oh good that was flashing
on there just yet oh god this isn't any
better hello hello huh okay cool I have
that now you dickbag eat long eat dingus
okay so that's broken apparently Edlund
Emily had a bit of a breakdown oh oh
there's nothing in it I take care of my
friends and I make them pretty ooh
don't turn Wow okay okay I got you I got
you I know what you're all about my
psychiatrist says I should start
recording to log to help with my
depression he doesn't know it's all
about Emily I can't tell him anything
about that but I'll record myself anyway
maybe it'll help okay thank you
mother dear how am I in relation to all
of this why do I have to be like that I
don't like it very much I like it none
at all
this seems bad by you not move order Oh
Oh what is that
oh what's that is that a but I see some
art but
look like an art but I guess that good
in everyone
I don't think so because I remember the
message that said let's play at midnight
and that's probably not good I'd rather
not how about you don't oh boy I think
they want to kill me oh what's that is
that a clue to the clue set upside down
I don't know what that means why does
all the door Z's go woozi this is the
wimpiest flashlight I've ever seen in my
life what else you got
bunch of anime watch an anime weeaboo
weirdos it's been over a month now and
the police still haven't found any leads
on the bizarre death of a local couple
why did I need a cause of death
oh oh okay oh oh all right then
oh oh okay oh okay oh okay oh great cool
awesome that was fun
why did I die I don't know
you know how to be these things people
they're not people
oh no I gotta go get the flashlight
again to the other way just on a whim
let's go go
TouchSmart wander around someone's house
not even trying to get out no I didn't
try the front door
maybe I should the horrible monstrosity
stop that oh I have the flashlight oh
this is good why this is where I died
look at this that's not good hi yep
that's a movin that's her movie mover
what you playing hide and seek playing
hide and seek out a better face cuz it's
really ugly
is that what we're doing owner if it's
just the one cuz it was the clown van
stomm don't look at her thanks for the
advice cool Oh woah woah woah woah woah
woah woah woah woah oh god she is
staring at me oh my goodness I would
rather not play this game anymore
oh this is as fast as I can run
apparently Oh God huh I just say in this
corner will I die
I don't know I don't know what that is I
don't know what's gonna troop Shoop
troop oh god where is she she better be
over here ah
hey how's it going there friend what are
you doing to your face looks like your
whole arms through it that's cool and
all but hey go to hell
that'd be great too also you know as an
aside note what Evers though you know
whatever I really thought that this this
this weird art was a but shows when my
brain thinks of all the time
I guess the laughs just means that she
relocates behind you which is cool huh
you saw her you little girl I guess
daughter of a [ __ ] friend of Emily I
suppose it's or anything that I'm
supposed to get I don't have enough
charcter I don't have charges oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh I have house shat my
pants on that one oh oh oh I should stay
out of the bedroom oh oh oh oh I don't
know I don't know I'm gonna turn my head
and I'm not gonna see her one time
what is that was this do they lock me up
down there where oh okay oh I know where
that is I think oh god there's not good
where's oh dear here was it here
oh god no do I go down why'd you stop
here we go
I guess I lost okay I have no idea how
to play this game so if you guys could
give me some advice then comment we
greatly appreciate what the hell do I do
I don't know so thank you everybody so
much for watching
give me some serious solid advice that'd
be great so thanks again and as always
I'll see you in the next video for dare
to horgiboum you who will get ready work
alright
touch Bob for 30 seconds
Oh do it again